all right kid listen up this part is
your universe saga it's weird it's gross
and this delicious normal fry is my
universe so you want to learn to be
spider-man really what what I want to
know is when I when I saw the trailer
for spider-man into the spider verse I'm
like I've never seen anything like this
before and I've watched a lot of
animated films or watch a lot of
superhero films I didn't this is
mind-blowing to me and the technology
involved but how did they pitch that to
you guys when it when they brought you
into it how did they describe what they
saw the project being I wasn't really
pitched if if I could be honest yeah it
was like you know spider-man Miles
Morales okay cool for me tapes and I'm
gonna hope for the best that's like I
think when you to me to me when you get
that call you're like Oh spider-man
they don't even they don't have to
finish I got an email from Phil Lord
years a couple years ago that said he
was writing this and he was thinking
about me for Peter Parker but he would
want me I would obviously have to
audition for it and was this something I
was interested in and obviously like you
said the answer is yes but then once we
got in they started talking about the
animation and how they saw it yeah and
it just makes you more excited right
exactly
you're like oh cool and it's gonna look
great yeah and I always liked working
with a creative who has a clear vision
yeah as opposed to like oh we'll just
put it together and then we'll test it
and see what we've got
yeah these guys knew what they wanted to
make from the start so it's been a real
pleasure jumping in so much depends on
the answer to this next question yeah
she makeup did you record the voiceover
for the movie a bunch of times and it
was it together was it where you did
they do the thing where you're kind of
in the same room so you can react to
each other or was it completely separate
we've done separate and we've done
together
oh yeah together is the best together is
the best because you actually I got to
figure out you know I've marina as Peter
Parker so I'm reading the material and
I'm trying to do it as best as they want
it but I'm hearing about miles and I'm
doing scenes with miles yeah I can tell
like alright so Peters annoyed he's mad
but it's different when
of a sudden shimmy comes in and brings
his energy yeah and we're facing each
other and I see like and we're a lot we
do improvise a little bit we add we're
allowed to try to like make each other
laugh or get mad so you start feeling
like oh so that's miles so it's no
longer on a script right now I'm Peter
that's miles and we're in it right now
yeah that's when any kids as an actor at
least for me it gets really fun yes I
heard this is random but I heard Gary
Busey say that he memorizes lines just
by reading them emotionless getting them
in his head but then getting with the
other actor to let the scene open up and
let it be what it's going to become
that's the first time Gary Busey's been
quoted weird right but right and that's
the thing like it exactly what I do but
I don't I sit in my head but then that
first rehearsal I always went - you're
like setting up lights I always try to
find the other actor and it'll be like
hey you want to run these a couple times
because you're not gonna really know it
until you hear how the other person says
it and then you remember yours well and
this is a pretty different version of
spider-man because we've never seen
Miles Morales before and so you're the
dude and I see it in your eyes like yes
I am ready for this response is I am
ready for this responsibility why is it
time
like why is why now um that's devant and
you know this one this past mean that's
a deeper question you know but I am I
think is it's time for the movie to come
out and it's time for it's time for some
positive role models for the youth in
general and I think that's why it's time
I think that's why Sony and Marvel are
like you know what let's go ahead and do
this animation let's go ahead and bring
light to Miles Morales let's help the
world let's think about it like that
like they're so pumped yeah the minute
you see Miles Morales everybody's like
yes they heard my prayers finally so
cool
yes well I'm so kind of as a result of
that your Peter Parker your Peter Parker
but also you're gonna like different
Peter Parker that's right may I say a
little schlubby and you're like a mentor
is Peter Parker at forty its Peter
Parker when he's been spider-man for a
long time and he doesn't know if he
still loves it
he doesn't know what it means to be
spider-man the allure of it all came and
went and then he's left with deal and
what it actually means to be spider-man
and what that means in terms of your
life right what it really means to be
spider-man and then he's put in a
situation where he meets somebody who
needs help and to become spider-man but
Peter Parker is not a teacher he's
spider-man so it's being something in
him he's getting pulled but then he sees
something special in this kid and that's
the yeah any other movie I think mmm-hmm
you ever find yourself like kind of
taking that role on a mentor with other
performers that haven't been through as
many things as you have yes whenever
you're on set with somebody and you
realize somebody's good but they're a
little bit new to the game you just do
little tweaks because you also know if I
help you relax in this moment with the
camera and you our scene is going to be
better mmm and I have had people the
elder statesman who are still doing it
to me yeah so I'll be on set and
somebody will say something and I'm like
I'm writing that down
that really helps like even tonight we
both learned from Gary Busey you learned
from him second hand that's right so
really you learn from me that is the
only time that will ever happen in my
life and it felt really good okay can
you come up with an like a specific
instance of when someone has schooled
you in a really loving way yeah I can
jon hamm and I just did the movie tag
together and we were doing press and one
of the things the press was we were
crashing a wedding and so we were
sitting outside of this bar in Miami and
the wedding was happening and the people
at the wedding were getting out of hand
with alcohol and I thought this is
promotional moves that could get out of
hand
because you got jeremy renner me I mean
that homes crashing a wedding and I go
you got one weird uncle who takes us the
wrong way we're getting beaten up at
this wedding I was like asking cause I
don't know if we do this maybe we don't
do then Jon Hamm said it's 90 seconds of
your life can you do this for 90 seconds
you could probably do just about
anything for 90 seconds so do it and I
took that advice I did the 90 seconds
the event worked the promotion worked
and I was really glad I just zipped my
lips and did 90 seconds hmm and as a
result I also am convinced that you and
John hammer also rivals in real life
like you were in tag so I just nailed
you nailed it that's acting usually
interview I have to have people remind
me that it's just a movie but like this
is your fan base so get ready he's my
rival um is spider-man into the
spider-verse
going to be opening up the spider-man
universe in a different way is that
something that you guys can speak to
because I know that people are like
questions are a poppin there's a
reference in the trailer
how many Spider Men are there save it
for Comic Con you say what's Comic Con
you gotta remember that line you know
why why because we know a Comic Cons do
you get what I'm saying nope all right
well you gotta watch the movie mystery
is alive smarter man into the spider
verse and I said there's like a whole
new thing on the horizon
look this is we're opening it up we're
like allowing new versions of this story
to be told I think it could very
possibly be it's very possible but on
this year's Christmas you know we will
see this movie in your answers your
questions will be answered I think if
everybody sees it and likes it it might
help answer more questions mm-hmm there
we go
okay so see it and like it and no way
don't tell all your friends